that man in Atlanta has been on a wave
and it is unbelievable 4070 that's a
joke it's never been done right it's
never been done that's stopping the game
worthy that is stopping the game worthy
what is it that kind of stands out to
you the most when I saw him at the
All-Star game he wasn't a big dude but
then when you see him in the Box he
seems like he's huge and then he hits
the ball and you're like that's
different that's different when it comes
off his Bat you're like that's different
it's so loud and so fast it's so Twitchy
give him one word that I would describe
him with is Twitch running swinging
throwing everything everything that ball
hit 120 come on bro the cameras caught
me making the face I would make that
face every single time the whole Dugout
did y'all just caught me it was
everybody that did that I thought it was
a technicality on the on the on the big
screen when it said 121 I said what I
said let me go look at the iPad and it
said
121.2 oh my God yes that's unbelievable